this is another example of a slightly
harder variety of mathematical induction
you can see the difference here as i've
highlighted up above is that whilst
we're used to dealing with
uh induction that goes n equals one two
three four five or even
you know five six seven eight nine those
all go up in
increments or gaps of one between each
different case
but the increment can be a value other
than one
in this case because we're looking at
positive odd integers the increment is
going to be
two so there's really kind of only one
extra thing to be mindful of which comes
when we're doing the proof step
uh but we're getting a bit ahead of
ourselves let's cross that bridge when
we get there why don't we just begin by
trying to prove this
from the start every proof by induction
is going to
begin with testing the base case now the
first
positive odd integer is n equals one
so let's go ahead and pop it into our
statement up above
our expression n squared minus 1
is going to be 1 squared minus 1 which
seems a bit weird
is 0 but 0 is divisible by every number
so therefore i can say great
it's true for the base case
that's one of the easy steps next
relatively easy step is to assume
that this is true for some arbitrary
n so i'm going to pick n equals k
and k has the same restrictions on it
that n has so
that means where k
is um i'm gonna i might as well use the
symbols
it's that's a positive integer
and k is odd
all right so let's just go ahead and
write the statement i'm going to have
what do we got here
k squared minus 1. now i want to state
this in an equation so it's easy to
manipulate i'm going to call this
equal to 8 p where p
is also going to be a positive integer
just like k
fantastic there's my inductive
hypothesis my assumption
now comes the part where there's some
real work this is the prove
step now as i mentioned before this is
where you need to be cautious there's
just a very subtle difference between
this
and other proofs by induction because
what we've got here are the positive odd
integers
the next odd integer is not going to be
k plus 1.
the next odd integer is going to be not
one different but
two different so instead of the next
allowable case
being n equals i should say
proof 4 n equals k plus 1 in this case
it's going to be k plus
2 and there's no reason why we can't say
you know
what if we had the multiples of 3 well
then it would be k plus 3 would be the
next case right or whatever number you
happen to choose
so in this case it's going to be k plus
2 what is that going
to look like well i guess i'm going to
have k plus
2 all squared minus 1. that's also going
to be divisible by 8.
so i'll call that 8q where q is also
an integer all right wonderful
so i've kind of set up my groundwork
here how do i make some progress
with this well i want to start off by
saying because i know that k
has to be odd that that means that k can
be written
with some particular properties applied
to it right
namely even numbers can be written as
doubled in integer
and odd numbers can be doubled in each r
plus one or double an integer
minus one okay so in order to say that i
can say
let k equal i need to be
double an integer i've used p and q
let's go with r
and just to make things simpler i'm
going to say plus 1 because
the less negatives are flying around the
better so i'll say 2r plus 1 where r
is also an integer now i'm going to gain
insight
out of this particular proof by
induction if i take this way of phrasing
k
and put it both into my inductive
hypothesis
and then also this thing i need to prove
the uh the k plus two
case in this case so what i'm gonna do
is i i need to be able to label these so
i can refer to them so let's call the
inductive hypothesis the assumption
let's call this one we'll call the k
plus two case
2. and now let's substitute
let's call this one 3 because i'm going
to have a lot of different things flying
around
let's substitute 3 into we'll begin
with the assumption we'll reshape the
assumption so it'll be more useful
for us to actually manipulate so what am
i going to get
i've got uh 2r plus 1
squared minus 1 that's apparently equal
to
8p that's me doing that straight
substitution clearly i can do some
simplifying and cancelling if i expand
my brackets here so i'm going to get
4r squared plus 4r
plus 1 minus 1 equals 8p
and then because these ones on the
left-hand side will cancel
that leaves me with four r squared
plus four r equals eight p
now it's tempting at this point too like
i can do even more cancelling right
um i can obviously divide through by
four but
for reasons they're going to become
clear later on i'm not
going to do any simplification or
cancelling here i'm going to leave that
as it is
this came from equation 1 so i'm going
to call it equation 1a
and i'll let you have a think maybe you
can work it out as i progress through my
um through my proof i want you to think
about why i didn't simplify this thing
which obviously can be simplified
okay i substituted this odd number this
odd expression for k
into equation one let's try putting it
into equation
two so i'm going to substitute into
now remember this is something i'm
trying to prove so i can't just
say equation i can't state equation
two is true but what i can do is i can
work with one side
of equation two and the left-hand side
is the part with a k in it so
let's substitute three into
the left-hand side of two
so what does that give us well there is
let's just highlight it so it's easier
to see
there is the left-hand side of equation
2. so when i put in my
2r plus 1 i get 2r plus 1
plus 2 all squared minus 1. okay so
there's my
left hand side let's go to work shall we
i've got
2r plus 3 all squared take away 1.
let's be careful with our binomial
expansion here so that's going to be 4
r squared double the product the product
in this case
is 6r so double the product is 12r
3 squared is then 9 and then i take away
1. okay
so far so good let's well we can tidy up
that 9 minus 1 on the
end there 4r squared plus 12r
that's going to be an 8 and that's
promising sign because i do want
8 this is a proof by divisibility by 8.
so that's fantastic
now at this stage here i have not
actually used my assumption
i haven't done any substitution of
anything from
equation 1 in here so if you have a
quick look up here you can see this was
me
working on equation 1. i called this 1a
this is what i can use to substitute in
and maybe now it's apparent to you why i
left that in the form
that it was i knew i was going to get a
4r squared down the bottom so i thought
well if i cancel that out that 4
and make it an r squared i'm just going
to have to multiply by 4 again
because you can see that's the 4r
squared which i got from
this expansion now my equation is not
quite ready to substitute into
this equation here has the 4r squared
but it doesn't have a 4r
at least not explicitly i can't find the
4r of course
all i need to do is separate it out from
within this 12r so that gives me a 4r
and an 8r that's a good sign again more
8.
i've got the plus 8 hanging out on the
end there and now at last i can make my
substitution
i can say that this whole thing on the
left hand side is 8p so what have i got
here
8 p plus this is looking fantastic 8r
plus 8. this is pretty much done at this
point
all i need to do is pull out that factor
of 8
and then that leaves me with p and r and
1. and this is going to be i can say but
hold on
p and r they're both positive integers
right so when you add positive integers
together you get
more positive integers so i can say well
this thing
uh is i think we called it q right
uh yeah right there this is the k plus 2
case this is going to be my q
h q where q is equal to
p plus r plus one uh and this
this is my k plus
two case
up here in fact i could even just make
it super obvious
i could put it back to b and q because
um that's just undoing the substitution
i did
right at the start of this i'm done i
can say
therefore true or statement is true
by principle of mathematical induction
so i would say
with these kinds of questions with these
more challenging inductions
i would just recommend you to look very
closely at the particular conditions
that have been applied
to the statement that's being uh that
we're being asked to prove like have a
look at what kinds of numbers
you have to deal with have a think about
where the numbers start if you pay close
attention to that
and adjust amend your proof by induction
process to
reflect that you should be fine